gunfire erupts outside of a high school
football game now a parent wants the
governor's office to intervene thank you
for staying with us i'm brian loftis and
i'm denise valdez it happened friday
night after the game that was played at
desert oasis high school 8 news now
reporter victoria saha spoke with
concerned parents this is the letter
parent christopher wagner sent to the
governor's office asking for help with
transparency after friday's fight we
live in las vegas
where the largest mass shooting ever
happened in the united states if there's
one city that should take this serious
it should be us this video showing how
intense things got with ccsd police
having to deploy pepper spray
then six shots were fired into the air
just by luck that someone did not get
hurt a statement wasn't released from
the school district until saturday
afternoon that said in part last night
we had a situation where individuals
were involved in an altercation after
the football game at some point shots
were fired into the air fortunately no
one was injured police are investigating
wagner says it took too long and was too
brief what i wanted to see was the
principal and the superintendent come
out and say we had a major event it got
so out of control we had a pepper spray
students we had to use a chemical agent
on them with few answers available from
the school district wagner decided to
write the letter to governor siselek if
i can't trust what's coming from school
administration about the safety and
well-being of my children who can i
trust ccsd police say this was the first
game that a fight involved a gun this
year victoria saha 8 news now police
have not found the person responsible
for firing that gun but they say they
have plenty of tips coming in they also
had the suspect would not have made it
through security and into the stands
with that gun